[Music]
Democrats and Republicans continue to
spar over the impending fiscal cliff the
deadlines coming up and that's why thank
you for stopping by you must be so busy
Oh busy no no no Christmas is less than
a week away shouldn't you be working on
that well no need the minds made it
clear the world's ending on December
21st there ain't gonna be Christmas this
year
oh-ho come on Santa and no one thinks
that's real oh sure it is why should I
bust my ass making a billion toys just
to see you melt in a rain of fire ho ho
only one day left I'm already working on
my bucket list your bucket list what's
that yeah I want to go back and watch
Breaking Bad from the beginning you know
you know I started watching during
season three but ever he's like no you
idiot you gotta start from there right
you really gotta start the beginning and
go through yeah also I want to crash a
Lamborghini through the front window of
a Bed Bath and Beyond I don't know why
I've always wanted to do that
that's for and I really want to taste
dolphin boy have you always wanted to
taste dolphin Conan come on or is that
just me that's just you Santa Santa what
if the world doesn't end on December
21st then I'll be the a-hole to ruin
Christmas
that doesn't matter to me I'm a Buddhist
see you folks
[Applause]